[Music]
hi friends
thanks for on this last day coming to
our talk an overview of cloud IIT core
I'm Gabe Weiss and I'm Gus class we're
engineers working on Google's cloud
platform specializing in IOT
we're gonna bring Gus back on a little
bit but first I want to have a little
chat with you guys first thing I need to
know who are you quick survey time who
out there our engineers are the people
that do in the work developers oh nice
okay most of you good do we have any
business managers sea-levels kind of
decision maker ease all right got a
couple here good don't worry I'm not
gonna actually call on any of you that's
good we call that theater of cruelty I
won't do that to you do we have any data
scientists in the crowd oh nice good
good good all right just to make sure
we're all on the same page who knows
what i OT is okay most of you what about
IOT core all right
good um just to make me feel better do
you all know what Google cloud platform
is even if you don't raise your hand
just make me feel good okay so for those
that haven't heard of it yet there I saw
a couple hands didn't go up IOT it's the
Internet of Things I actually voted for
5ti things that talk to the Internet I
thought it would have been a little more
indicative what it is so what is IOT a
computer your computer connected to
Wi-Fi IOT device your smartphone IOT
device smart meters connected your house
electricity gas all of those I have T
devices raspberry pi's micro controllers
we'll get to all of these all of these
are IOT devices in 2015 Business Insider
along with Gartner did a study that said
by 2020 30 billion connected devices 30
billion IOT devices that's the the
phones and the computers you can see are
a tiny slice of what we're talking about
here so why aren't we there yet why
isn't my world connected and smart well
these things take time they take money
so to really understand what the holdup
is I want to do a little brief
introduction to the world of world
electronics
does anyone know if I say the word
constrained device does anyone know what
that is a constrained device a couple
people are nodding okay
a constrained device is a tiny computer
it's got its memory its processor its
analog to digital signal conversion all
in a single chip
that's a constrained device so because
everything's on that single chip
it's called constrained because it's
memory it's processing its storage are
all severely limited this is the class
of computer we're talking about when we
talk about 30 billion connected devices
who remembers floppy disks and I'm not
talking about hold on hold on I'm not
talking about the three-and-a-half inch
you know firm ones five and a quarter
inch the really floppy ones all right
now I know some of us are old enough
that remember there were bigger ones
right there like the dinner size plate
ones those aren't the ones I'm talking
about the five and a quarter inch
floppies those things held 360 K of
storage these microcontrollers hold less
than that on average if we remember
those floppy disks a single program came
on many disks so to load an application
we had to switch those things in and out
to load your program into RAM we don't
have that luxury with microcontrollers
we can't just swap them in and out to
load an application that's why we need
something a more powerful computer or
cloud IOT core to expand the
capabilities of the device so since I
keep bringing it up I want to make sure
we're all on the same page with IOT core
what is IOT core it's a 100% managed
service this means that you don't have
to stand up anything you don't have to
put a service up in a VM we handle all
of that for you in Google there's no
need for auto scaling redundancy scaling
all of that is done by the cloud for you
IOT core provides a global endpoint no
matter where your devices are in the
world it's the same endpoint so latency
is to your nearest data center and back
and that's it IOT core has two main
pieces it's a communication broker and
it's a device management for IOT core
the organization of it is you have IOT
core inside you create registries
registries are buckets for your devices
so you can create some some logical
organization to them and then the
devices yourselves the messages from
your devices will using either HTTP or
the MQTT protocol shuttle your devices
data up into the cloud and
io2 core brokers that's the
communication piece your message is from
IOT core into cloud pub/sub and we'll
talk about pub/sub later pub subs our
event stream manager and from there it's
the gateway I o T core gives you access
to the rest of Google clouds platform so
to wrap your head around why where we
are now and why it's really getting
excited I want to go back to our little
history lesson and talk about how
Electronics evolved in the before times
your household stuff like your blender
your microwave your washing machine all
of these were made up of electronic
components like capacitors diodes
resistors things that would respond to
electric signal strength alone the more
power for the signal the more it would
happen in electrical components so your
microwave for example how it works the
magnet the magnetron inside your
microwave you increase signal strength
to it your food gets hotter decrease
signal strength to it and it reduces the
temperature that's how basic electronics
work because the of the physical
relationship of these components to each
other
as the electrical signal come in each
component would actuate or not actuate
the next piece is in it's like a Rube
Goldberg machine and because of the
tight physical relationship to it change
was very difficult if you wanted to
change functionality of your electrical
circuit you had to make physical changes
to it you had to change your bomb your
building material so there would be cost
associated with it the minute you add
something to an electrical circuit your
resistance goes haywire you might have
to change the whole layout of your
circuit if you wanted to mass-produce
your circuits this is a problem once
you've created your tooling for your
manufacturing line on your circuit mass
producing the same templates nice and
easy
if you've introduced change and now you
have to retool everything to recreate
your circuits so it's very expensive to
make any kind of change some of these
kinds of circuits we call in the analog
circuits still exist today
but modern electronics and why this is
all exciting are a little bit different
modern electronics are still composed of
sensors components actuators all of
these things that still work with
electrical signals but instead of the
way that we used to do it where signal
strength was what changed things now we
have things called digital protocols
electrical signal will go on and off
very rapidly in a predefined pattern a
digital protocol that is understood by
another piece in the circuit this means
that
we can Center our electronics around
this constrained device this
microcontroller which is very good at
reading signals both analog and digital
and speaking in this digital protocol
the chip itself can now create
functional change in your circuit
without having to physically change
anything around it it's important
because they're inexpensive until
relatively recently these
microcontrollers were pretty expensive
but now mass-market I can go out and buy
a microcontroller with Wi-Fi and
bluetooth for less than five dollars so
adding these complex circuits and
creating these complex circuits is now
very inexpensive the trade-off of course
is that microcontrollers are still
relatively constrained they don't have a
lot of memory they don't have a lot of
storage so they need something else to
help them achieve the capabilities that
they're not able to accomplish on their
own so hopefully this gives you kind of
a backdrop for why we're at this tipping
point with electronics where cost and
complexity have arrived where we can do
things at scale being able to create
these cheap complex circuits with the
microcontrollers allows us to think
about creating those cheap or
inexpensive complex smart devices that
are going to connect our world so take a
step and let's talk about smart devices
what is a smart device at the simplest a
smart device is something that can
complete an objective that can do a task
without human intervention I don't need
to do anything for it
modern electronics and the available
ability of these microcontrollers makes
intelligent control of these devices
economically feasible and you might
notice I'm really harping on
economically feasible and inexpensive
and I am if there's just one takeaway
that I want you to walk away from this
talk with it's that what a few years ago
might not have been possible because of
cost and complexity is easily achievable
now we have the tools now to create
these ecosystems of smart devices so
smart devices so we can understand them
there's three basic approaches to a
smart device and I'm holding all three
fingers first there's a hundred percent
on device everything is contained and
done within your single device something
like Google home where I can use my
voice as the input to a device it uses
speech to text to convert to text it
uses natural language processing to
analyze what I really asked for because
maybe
didn't ask for the right thing and run
some kind of task on device and it can
accomplish it all without me having to
do anything else I have a spoken word
and something happens it might use the
Internet to call out to do something
else but that's part of the task it's
already accomplishing the second there's
edge or border routing sometimes we call
it as the the radio Protocol approach
for example Nest has released something
called open thread open thread allows
your device to call out to another
nearby device to take advantage of its
capabilities so say you've got a device
that can do everything except internet
but whatever the task is it needs to be
able to call out to the Internet well if
open thread it can reach out to another
another device that's nearby and
connected and borrow its internet
connection in order to accomplish its
task it's still doing some of the work
onboard but it's using these other
devices to finish off what it needs to
be done and lastly a device can delegate
all of its control to something else a
lot of the times these microcontrollers
do that so they will become a very dumb
but very fast gatherer of information
gatherer of data and then hand off all
of that i/o to something else a computer
nearby the cloud something else firmata
made famous by Arduino that's the
perfect example of what this is over a
serial wire you can delegate all of your
control all of the the information that
you've gathered on one device to a
computer to something else nearby so
what if I told you that the computer
that we're connecting to that's knit
that is doing all of this power for us
didn't have to be anywhere near the
devices and that's where we're back
that's what we're back to IOT core this
side you can start to think about that
like the concept of Fermanagh IOT core
connects your device to the cloud it
expands the capabilities of this little
device and all of its data is collecting
to the power of the cloud it gives your
device these new capabilities without
any adding any complexity you don't need
more local hardware you don't need
anything local all you need to be able
to do is talk to the cloud so all of
this so far that our history and
electronics are talking about smart
devices is to hammer this point home
where we're in a world where creating
devices that talk to the Internet it's
not only easy it's inexpensive there's
that inexpensive again we can all do it
so I've touched on why the cloud is
integral to IOT
but just in case you aren't convinced
yet I want to show you a couple of
things to make sure that you understand
let's take a look at this graph this
graph is all of the oil and gas fields
in the Gulf of Mexico there's a little
over 1300 of them each of these gas
fields could have potentially thousands
of sensors all streaming data to keep
our math simple let's say it's just a
thousand from there let's say that each
of these sensors is only streaming a
hundred bytes a second noting 100 bytes
a second even if that's true that's 137
megabytes a second it's just over 8
gigabytes a minute it's 11 and a half
terabytes a day you could manage that
data if you want I'm just saying there's
a reason the cloud was created the cloud
offloads all of the infrastructure all
of the overhead of managing this big
data you don't have to worry about
backups you don't have to worry about IT
people to run your machines and make
sure you've got uptime the cloud handles
all of this the other point I want to
talk about is security some of you may
have heard about it a couple years ago
there was a thing called the Murai
botnet attack this is where a bunch of
unsecured devices mostly routers and
stuff like that
were hijacked and used to attack the
domain name services of the internet Dyn
took down huge swathes of the internet
for a pretty good amount of time in the
in the internet scheme also a a
temperature sensor in a fish tank last
year this happened a temperature sensor
in a fish tank in a casino was
compromised the hacker was able to
through this temperature sensor pull out
all of the personal information of the
casinos high rollers all through a
temperature sensor that didn't happen to
be secured so security is massively
important if you're doing IOT you need
to think about security IOT core
registers all of your devices with an
ssl key pair and does all your encrypted
communication through TLS 1.2 or later
to ensure that all of your devices are
secure when they're talking to the cloud
so we understand now hopefully why IOT
core is awesome but what else
IOT core is this gateway into the Google
cloud platform what does the cloud
platform have for you for IOT this is a
small sampling of what Google cloud
platform offers if you want a really
good time go to cloud kugel comm slash
products and start scrolling and just
keep scrolling and keep scrolling it's
really impressive there's there's enough
products on there that even we don't
know what all the products really do
they're all specialized there's a ton of
products that will fit pretty much any
need that you want but back to our
sample so first we've got our devices
bringing their data up into GCP as I've
talked about before these payloads the
messages and brokered as events end up
cloud pub/sub our event managing manage
our event stream manager from there once
it's in pub/sub we have some products
that can respond to our incoming
messages we've got cloud functions cloud
functions our serverless functions that
just exist in the server list space that
you can call either with an endpoint
like you're calling a URL or they can
respond to events within GCP in our case
the pub/sub message coming in will
trigger a cloud function to run on it
the other product we've got on here is
called cloud dataflow dataflow is our
managed service to handle transforming
incoming streams it's managed so again
like cloud IOT core it will scale
without you having to do anything
however much data it's processing it
will scale to handle it it can be used
to do things like filter incoming data
if there's only some data you want to
make it into your final storage or it
can massage the data into a specific
format if you need it to be processed in
a specific way it also acts as a
pipeline for your data cloud pub/sub is
temporary messages will stay there for
seven days if you don't do something
with them they go away don't want your
day to go away so a product like data
flow can shuttle your data into the
other products which brings us to our
storage and analytics section there's
way more than are shown here these three
are just a very small sampling of what
we've got first we have BigTable
BigTable is our no sequel storage or
sequel database option again managed
service it will scale with however much
data you put in it
bigquery is our enterprise level data
warehousing it allows you to query your
big data petabytes of data with simple
sequel statements that means your data
analysts and your data scientists don't
have to learn a new system they can just
use sequel to find insights within your
data they can spend their time analyzing
data not learning a new system and
finally we've got machine learning
tensorflow is the open source software
that allows you to train your models and
run inference against your models cloud
machine learning engine is hosted
tensorflow it allows you to harness all
of the power of google's backbone to
train and run inference on your models
faster and more efficiently finally we
have tools that can visualize your data
we've got a couple of options here we've
got cloud data lab it's built on Jupiter
so you can build notebooks to visualize
the data however you want and we've got
an out-of-the-box solution data studio
which lets you look at time slices of
data in charts and graphs however you
want to visualize it so for IOT with all
of these together you can do things like
perform device management and monitor
your health across fleets of devices you
can warehouse and analyze truly absurds
amount of data and lastly you can
perform things like predictive
maintenance on me and manufacturing your
utilities to see when your stuff is
going to break using tools like machine
learning cloud IOT core provides that
gateway it provides the device
management and connectivity for all of
your devices into the rest of Google
cloud platform it's been only a year
last year IO is one we announced cloud
IOT core so I want to take a sec just to
highlight the what we've done since then
what are the improvements we've made
first when we when we announced that
beta a year ago it can only talk MQTT if
you didn't have a device again do MQTT
you're out of luck we've added HDPE HTTP
since then so now a broader range of
devices can connect to IOT core and have
their data managed a year ago when we
launched each registry remember those
buckets of devices map one-to-one to our
pub sub so any device data that was
coming into your registry would only go
into a single bucket of pub/sub we've
now added the ability to map multiple
pub subtopics to a single registry so
you can charge your data that way you
can organize your data into multiple pub
subtopics we've added stack driver
stack driver logging so that you can
monitor your health through stack driver
which is that's a logging and monitoring
tool that we've got I forgot to mention
it before and brand-new and I don't
think anyone's actually announced this
yet so I'm kind of excited I get to
announce something Android things I'm
sure you've all heard a lot about
Android things across this conference
Android Things has created a plugin that
they're releasing next week
that will allow you to easily connect
your Android things devices to IOT core
so all of those sessions that you went
to about Android things and all the cool
stuff you can create using it now let
that kind of
late in the back your mind what more can
you do with it if it's connected to the
cloud what else can you do what global
reach can you accomplish with Android
things now that it can connect to cloud
IOT core so now that I've talked your
ear off I'm gonna bring guests back up
and he's going to show you in practice
some of the stuff that I've been talking
about thanks Gabe let's have a round of
applause for Gabe and his wonderful blue
hair look at this guy yeah I don't know
how I'm gonna follow that just kidding
actually I'll be the yin to his yang and
I'll show you the things that he's been
talking about so this is actually the
this is the third time that I've given
that I've shown kind of the nuts and
bolts of how cloud IOT core works and
kind of this is AI home right now and I
remember a year ago the cloud IOT core
team came in front of you all and
demonstrated the demonstrate of the
product for the first time and when they
did it I I have no idea how they were
able to get such a robust in beautiful
demo at that point in time because there
was a lot of pieces that the experience
was a cliff you know the first time that
I showed the first time that I should
this Dibble that I'm just about to do
the it it blew up in my face and that
was because it was for a couple of
reasons one of them was we didn't have
that we didn't have the the cloud
console features for IOT core so there
was no visual way of doing of adding
devices and creating registries and
there also there also was no
command-line utilities for managing IOT
core and so I had to write a sample that
would make API calls with the device ID
the registry ID the project ID all these
values that are really easy to
fat-finger so when when we went to
general availability the Google Cloud
SDK or G clout for those who for those
who don't know google cloud ships the
command-line utility that's written in
Python I believe and it allows you to do
all the things that you can do in cloud
programmatically from the command line
and it actually works it works really
well from from cloud resources and if
you go and do the code lab I actually
how do you do
a lot of cloud resource management using
the G cloud SDK and so today I'm going
to show you how did you how to how to do
the nuts and bolts of cloud IOT core
just using the cloud SDK as opposed to
using the the console or the command
line or some API calls that I pack
together in some sort of sample app so
I'll just unlock my machine and we'll
switch to computer all right can
everybody see that
good bigger smaller good okay okay
awesome alright so if you remember the
entry point into cloud IOT core is
Google cloud pub/sub and so before we
can before we can receive messages and
transmit and before we can transmit
messages and then process those messages
from pub/sub we have to create a Google
cloud pub/sub topic so I'm going to
create a Google cloud pub/sub topic
I'm super nervous that I type really bad
okay top okay so I just hide in G cloud
pub/sub topics creates IO 2018 top four
topic and so now I do G cloud pub/sub
subscriptions so the subscriptions will
of course my sub and I forget the help
alright so when you create the
subscription you have to associate that
subscription with the topic and then I
have to create and if you see me
struggling up here and know how to fix
what I'm doing don't hesitate to yell
that alright alright here we go - dos
topic alright so now I have created a
Google cloud pub/sub subscription that
is associated with the with the google
cloud pub/sub topic so now whenever I
publish messages into that topic then
they get queued up in the subscription
and I can pull those those messages from
the subscription so now I'm going to
create a Google cloud IOT core registry
and I'm not the best typer in talker and
so associated with this registry is
going to be an event notification
configuration and so what that just
means is when messages are sent to let
me treat messages which could be
something like sensor data from a device
when those messages come in then this is
this is where this is the topic where
those where those notifications can go
to and so you can also set you can also
set this so that like you can have event
notifications going to other types of
things and we and the future may offer
other other ways of connecting with
clout so now I created a registry and
after it now that it's nother to the the
registry will contain devices that
represent the identity of of these of
your of your smart devices or IOT you
can internet connected devices and so
now I'm ready to add a to device and so
the device connects using an
asynchronous to credit or an
asynchronous encrypted credential so you
encrypt you pet you give us your public
key and then you encrypt your data with
your private key when you authorize its
and you get a JSON web token and so what
this is going to do is invoke a couple
of I I can never type those open SSL
commands correctly so but really what
this all this is doing is just calling
this open SSL command which will
generate a public private key key pair
with with jok compatible algorithms and
so now that I have my device keys I can
I can register a new device
and I'm gonna call e 2e because that's
the device that I recommend using for
the intent example and if you want to
follow if you want to follow on your own
through a through a step-by-step example
you can find this in the documentation
at cloud Google com /i ot and so when I
create this when I create this device
I'm going to have I'm going to use the
I'm going to use the the e C key that
was created with open SSL and then I
give it the es 256 string representing
the type because that is just the the
signing type that's that's correctly
named for furred JWT and after this
comes back then we're ready to connect
to Google Cloud IOT core and so this is
going to use I'm just for this example
I'm just going to use the HTTP example
which is the most basic connected way of
connecting to Google platter to core so
this is just a Python sample and so
there's the converts the project ID
that's the you know the cloud resource
associated that with the device registry
and the and the pub subtopic and so
forth and then the registry ID which is
the container for these devices and the
device and ID and everything else that
you saw me put in in the previous
message and now docker is going to ask
me to update I'll do that later okay so
alright so when the so here's the job
that is calculated from the device and
because it's a brand new device you'll
see that it's configuration is empty and
it's also the shish yeah that's nice
nice stack trace but here's the so
here's the configuration for the device
and you can see that I've published it
published a couple of telemetry messages
that will that are events representing
something that this device is
transmitting to the cloud and so now if
I use g-cloud again hub
and I could do subscriptions hole all
right I'm gonna forget the name again
switchin is IO 2 0 1
and when I do this I should see the
messages I should see those telemetry
messages that were transmitted by the
virtual device to the cloud this is
always a scary part there it is so sorry
for my sorry for how this looks kind of
funky in here but you can see the you
can see attributes which is like
metadata for the device that connected
the time that and and and anything else
that you want to push into your topic
inside of this data field alright so if
you've seen any of the talks before on
cloud IOT core you see me do this a lot
of different ways this can work but
these devices are really this but this
is it you've seen the entire you've seen
the entire capabilities of the cloud
once those messages are in pub/sub then
you can process those with all the cloud
resources that Google provides and so
this could be this could mean processing
image data and then returning labels or
reacting to some sort of condition
inside of that image or this could mean
warehousing massive fanon of data and
then being able to do analytics in real
time with it and so that's fun but we're
gonna do something a little bit
different today and I want to show you
some I want to show you this working on
hardware and so I have brought with me a
an Arduino device and this has sort of
been a 20% project of mine it's an
experimental library and for those who
don't know Arduino is a physical
computing platform that's very popular
in education and with makers and it
allows you to do things like blink
lights actuate door or you know actually
electro like electronic things which
kind of parks back to what gig was
speaking about with modern electronics
so modern electronics can easily be
controlled and actuated from the from
Arduino devices and so I'm going to do
something so that virtual devices are
really good for things like load testing
and
and like learning about learning about
the product and then the our
experimental library with Arduino which
I cannot recommend that you go with go
to production yet as it says on my
github account look out its my code and
it's also Alvaro's so thank you all
borrow for all your contributions and
and anyone who's interested in
contributing to our Arduino project is
welcome to and so now I'm going to go
from that virtual device which is you
know something is useful for loading to
a physical real world device that we can
then use for that we can then use for
prototyping and other things to get an
idea about like when when you have your
actual device built on you know one of
the one of the the more robust solutions
that our partners often offer but so in
order to work with our team we know you
can just install the library using the
library manager and then after that
libraries installed inside of the
examples will appear Google Cloud IOT
four-jaw and inside of here each of
these there is is a sketch an argument
of sketch is just a way of like a you
know a way of specifying a source file
and then it's the and it's what is open
inside of the IDE and so inside of the
sketches this is this header file CI HCC
config and then inside of here are all
of your your configuration that we just
did in the virtual device except as
specified with this physical device and
I'm just going to connect to a Wi-Fi and
it's everything else
and this is the same configuration that
I just that I just use from before did I
this yes
that say
or the project ID oh yes yes so the
project ID is thank you thank you yes
this could have saved you a lot of
frustration in a minute but yeah so the
project ID is that yeah the reason the
cloud resource is associated with your
with all the things you created a topic
and then there is a and then I'm going
to do a transform on the private key
which I'm going to use as for creating
the connection credential and this is a
open SSL command that I can never
remember but maybe for yeah there's okay
so now I've taken that private key and
I've turned it into this string that
looks a lot like this string and then
I'm just gonna replace this string with
that string
yeah very soon now when I click the run
up thank you
we're doing a good job that's okay
and I make sure you have the right word
okay and this is a we recently I added
this sport for the genuine boards these
are kind of like the Arduino style
boards they they have a feel to them
that's kind of that's kind of nice
anyways so now that I have now that this
device has connected let's see me with
my logs here
I know something is wrong
[Music]
let's see
but the private key is wrong did I do
the public one thank you you're the best
and this should be EC try this again
face it
oh I need to save the sketch
sorry
which has again and it seems I said
again oh yeah actually this - no this is
SOR do we know strings do support this
so this is this isn't working isn't
expected let's see here though
sometimes the time server doesn't return
the right time and that can get me
and so if this there you go okay so now
it's working yeah so this is an
experimental library everybody and I'm
yeah so heed my advice yes and that's
why you don't shouldn't use in
production yet but maybe someday so now
so this in this sample like if the
configuration message is set to
something other than the value one only
one light will be on on the board and
then if I set the configuration message
to one so the configuration for this
device is set to 1 instead of 0 or hello
then that then 2 lights on the board
should turn on and let's see we'll set
it to 1 and then everybody watch on that
screen it's the the light that comes on
is on the left side of the board I think
and so we just updated the device
configuration and then through my
blazing fast internet connection there
it is yeah all right ok and so this is
nice
devices are fun and being able to
prototype stuff with Arduino is
fantastic actually because you're able
to do stuff really quickly and you're
able to in just a short period of time
and inexpensively get to have an
understanding of whether or not
something will actually work
to the micro who my mic is on
do I need to get close to you
can we use can we use this mic oh I
still attached that's gonna end poorly I
just need to get really close to you
guys here it's gonna be a great game of
telephone so three weeks ago
Gus needed to do a demo to this
conference yeah he had nothing so he
went to the sound guy who's getting him
a new battery pack he had some lights he
had some project is working with with
LEDs and we're back yeah let's see if
his sound guy all right and so yeah I
had lights and and I thought I thought
you all would be much more excited if I
showed you robots and and so I had this
toy it's a toy like this I want to show
you what under here so it's this toy and
this little toy has a remember game was
talking about digital systems on and
offs
well this toy has something that I saw
this on this toy it's got an infrared
receiver and and it has this little
remote associated with it which I have
smudged off any thing that will hint at
what it actually is but this little this
little this little toy responds to a
blinking light on here and I just showed
you a blinking light so what if instead
of that little light these signals these
commits these configuration messages
that are translated to the devices are
then instead interpreted into the motion
commands for this little toy and I
thought that was cool and so I tried I
started prototyping and on the board's
very similar to that other one I showed
you and I came up with this my friend
added some player and some character to
this little guy and so what happens is
when the device comes online the it
should wiggle a little bit
and that way I will know it's connected
to the Wi-Fi so there's a little
blinking light that indicates the
various stages of the boots and I'm
gonna I'm gonna start a flask app
alright there it is so when it just nods
it nodded its little head there what was
going on was it's now connected to its
now connected to Wi-Fi oh you do your
thing okay it's now connected to Wi-Fi
and this is not the device and now I can
go into my device registry here again
and I can send configuration messages
and then control this and what's what's
interesting is that no longer is it
something that's like a device that's
locally here this device could be
anywhere and it doesn't really it's and
like at the end there could be millions
of these devices and you can do things
like coordinate across those devices
anyway so let's send a configuration
message to the device that will cause
the device to turn its head and so when
the device responds to the command it
should just nudge a little bit there
there it is
okay and so you'll also notice that on
the front of this device I have added a
sonar sensor and that sonar sensor will
pretty accurately measure distance up to
about 30 meters away and so let's just
do it looks like I wanted to do
something that shows like you know
getting data from your device's putting
that data into the cloud and then
processing that data so we very similar
to what we do in the code lab and so I
created that little flasks app and then
this little flasks app has this UI that
only a developer could love but when I
click that button it sends a
configuration change a configuration
message to this device if I'm lucky if
it's not cached
see and and that configuration message
will trigger this device to start moving
in this sort of sonar pattern and I mean
these are toys so I mean it's not gonna
turn exactly the same amount of degrees
every time but it's close enough that we
can kind of get a general idea for the
surroundings around this robot and then
on the blazing fast internet to Mike
computer it should render oh that's nice
okay
still good it's still good all right and
so then we render it's alright to clap
so then we render so a graph kind of of
the surroundings of this device and so
adding it so adding the internet
capabilities to this toy was as easy as
adding just adding a hat on top of it
and also the the because of because of
the the low requirements for the
hardware for for cloud IOT core I'm able
to build these hats at a cost of you
know maybe just five dollars and so you
can imagine that you can imagine in your
factory or in your store or in your
office or wherever that were you
wherever you have these these modern
electronic systems that you can
communicate with with Internet connected
devices then you can add internet
capabilities to those devices and
because they're because they're so
inexpensive we actually no longer have
to show my laptop the it's actually
possible to produce a large number of
these devices in a relatively short
period of time and then kind of have
some fun with them so after the sometime
after this conference I'm gonna try to
open-source to software so if you all
want to make your own little Internet
connected toys and kind of get an idea
for how these kinds of things work you
can check it out and for now I'm gonna
do the thing that everyone wants me to
do whenever I show them the robots and
that is make them move as a swarm army
okay and it's a it's at times like this
that I really appreciate how little data
the cloud IOT core product sips because
I am totally not using my phone for
connecting these devices totally is
all right we should have a bunch of
online
there we go okay
and it's just about time for them to
March
all right
and we'll go back to and thank you gage
for wrangling all these robots all right
since then oh look out robots go it's
the Wi-Fi it's probably the Wi-Fi but I
mean they're blinking really pretty
though they are blinking really pretty I
feel pretty good about that
there they go yeah so there it is thank
you we have a jumper oh all right all
right they've already become attention
this one's trying to break free yeah yes
I also wanted to do this just to make
this Sunday gave haptic dancer out on
stage all right so let's go back to the
slides and we'll just wrap up okay so so
so going back to so going back to other
other approaches to to adding smart and
intelligent capabilities to your devices
we would be you know we I want to again
say you know like there's other ways of
doing this than just complete
delegations in the cloud you can use
edge border routing to to use to extend
the capabilities of nearby devices to
other devices you can use on divide
smarts with things like Android things
so if you have all the capabilities
without the cloud or some capabilities
shared with the cloud Android thinks is
really great way to do this and also
there's a we have stack as Gabe
mentioned at the very beginning we have
stackdriver logging and and snatch
driver logins or some people can get
them a lot of information about things
like security audits and other like in
that combined with the metadata of
devices may be enough for a lot of what
people's IOT needs are and because
because we went a little bit over of the
wrap up quickly and all that gate closes
out so we want to hear from you how you
about the the this talk so please go
here and enter in our talk the cloud IRT
overview thank you for coming if you
wanted
[Applause]
[Music]